الصراع الروسيه الاوكرانيه صراع ازلي
ازجته الحرب الروسيه الاخيره التي بدات في
فبراير من العام الماضي حرب لا يعرف ان
كانت ستنتهي ام لا الا ان وثيقه
استخباراتيه امريكيه مسربه حددت اربعه
سيناريوهات غير متوقعه لنهايه هذه الحرب
السيناريوهات الاربعه مشاهدينا تحدثت عن
افتراضيات اما بمقتل الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين او مقتل الرئيس الاوكراني
او ازاحه القياده داخل القوات المسلحه
الروسيه او ضربات اوكرانيه على الكريم
سيناريو ضربه اوكرانيا للكريم لن يحتمل
ويحتمل مجموعه واسعه من الاثار المحتمله
حيث يمكن ان يؤدي لتصعيد رصيد
اما باطلاق تعبئه عسكريه واسعه النطاق
والنظر في استخدام الاسلحه النوويه
التكتيكيه او احتماليه دفع ب التفاوض على
تسويه لهذه الحرب مخاطر مثل هذا الهجوم من
قبل اوكرانيا هي احد اهم الاسباب التي
جعلت الولايات المتحده متردده في تزويد
اكياس بصواريخ بعيده المدى وفقا هنا
لصحيفه نيويورك تتحدث الوثائق السريه
الامريكيه ايضا عن دفاعات ثياب الجويه
الحاسمه لمواجهه الضربات الروسيه وعن
المساعدات الدوليه للقوات الاوكرانيه كم
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه التي سربتها
الوثائق دفعت مشاهدينا البنتاجون لاعتبار
عمليه تسريب هذه تشكل خطرا جسيما جدا على
الامن القومي للولايات المتحده خاصه لما
قد تحتوي هذه الوثائق المسربه من معلومات
مضلله لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات